hey what's up everyone welcome the
simulation eurostyle saw a brush and
psychosis the cancer cells feature of
I lubricate software for second annual
partnership with and how arno speaking to
hans hello hi how you dance for coming
out so so out pleasure river and
very excited to be  talking about things
photography video clip grecian innovation
in the space in the future of the us
really cool and learn the barnes hans
houses points layer seminar views the
president of sleep oil in a likes to
user a marker research practical for
photo and video industry as one piece
scenarios is the chervil first
budget car lease colony innovation a
partnership in photo and video ecosystem
and also his first born iphone case
site
live center inland flashy photo and
video specia
de summers innovation collaboration the
comeback in chrome of browser and
worksheets ruben productions wigan
explosion die  left in construction and
millions and that sounds like love
first round winn  ie the branches butcher
do you like gate interested in
photography in video in spread so
early me try both legs in head
in electronic publishing more photography
and he rested first job was for a
photoshop plugin
startup developer a way back
so who is some kind or  a tellie
creative facts to photoshop buckets
interest in arnhem in there was a
ready
artificial intelligence before version
of Koolwijk time anyway the niro
brooches became 512 artistic effect that
you can apply to your photos
how the boys this was early nineties
for that trail fargo
and after  asked for company but life
picture white was a sweet photoshop
competitor the thio time was john scolea
of the left apple and who prayed this evil of in
ovation such computing' becam
photoshop the primary how to work with
ery very large images and many ways
imps  die en lightroom and
non-destructive editing that can of stuff
you could already there
services use the concept of laye  rs yes oh
my gosh
players becomes san diego has the import
adwords in the bio that yes yes
i think i know you measure the right now shout
that delivers via reddit in programs or
in epheze fills took over for software
company ben bek en toe
produce electrons and c7  risk start it's
research company and that was just ben
smartphone photography videos out the
garden you got that iphone for which for
just about to write quality of camera
that type of field and you what i know i take
a photo with my iphone something sexy
mom sharing
chickens  tickler no sally yes the pictures will
be so sober and the joest
go and feel to red light hipstamatic was
a fun for span en den berg such
intense that instagram see this look like
pastel you can of 10 to your images and
the look like hatching en  the process
that
iphone and a reader that android phones
big a letter in the photocapture
capabilities the filters how les cent
show in order to make up for sharing
what's wrong time the was a drawer of
destruction a  nd led house took the
surfed mobile photography
and that he is bingo imam and is in this
point for his still going on it who
left some kind of content mortgage photos
would the chief keep photos people photos
how they create fox a photo product and
order  that of your iphone so the ladder the
whip single in homes and the heavy
going on in the very short time frame
yes and mono disgust also about positive and
tanks one of the things you stiff
how so interesting learning about tiger
phoebe you access the us all ah  and how in
the first meeting it is vlogs tower
draw history pieces freesia buzzword
at
pedagogy dots just for ap capture
and now digital photo stability and
viewer on twitter disturbed
what's TV in the house lesson picasa
experts on technological can go further and
deeper the also  in the lens is
then you are the pressing is can baron show
well fun and the photos there in more easily
able to be uploaded and explaining what
a software of the differin technical
discs
tells about this croy this pic yesterday
perspective on how you see no the last
door here we can see in those
circles multi-language there just fine
yes ok yes that token keeps the audience
irish and how long live in following this
page you feel  a relatively new if you
porn and the bourne a race en de dit
your doctor om boszhard to imagine how film
photography fortress en en most
pointing there is your a few
you to a photo we de filmcamera you
could en view your photo
zo de johanna  you well you for both use
to that god was better on the video
and was a photo with you juni the
a film that velp you are not to eprint
it and oil ben did you see how that
photo toe and old and ned was or  is again
cashcow for company's like kodak
and ekva zo zo in those days people were
very
selective in went to take a photo
recovery photo you to cost man i know
it's free and basically hard disk space
is om oostfri cloud store free space is
so cheap it  sometimes food  dsel i friso want
you in one er of buttons and
abundance photography
it's fascinating that hollow chains i
have another focus on it's nice for my
industry perspective the that's
interesting in that longueur dual
graphics game of and were heading is
that so sweet  for my team at the end of all
those innovations in the
in the root of photography then with
imaging fender stem even so dave and
download
the tendon refill because you have that flexible
film so that 5 mm and loss such a
porticoed
shooting in color where  your
popular
the cameras leak hippest alright the
assent of kodak
what all those inventions and oils changes
the tea
the composer came from within the
imaging industry and room think my
against that kind and he is doodling in
the space
the imaging industry adapter and was
james fowler quickly and en de en ladder
so on ginkgo someone who innovation
escape from outside the imaging
industry
like was nolan we into the codex that i
would be and you
nightgowns
that changed since they and dep the tool
changes antiquity industry and the the very
first man was these clothes program' like
photoshop coming to the world so you will
enhance the studio photos in in you well what
many ways and and what fun a nice
board with photoshop is your good if they also do
everything operations like your hands go
to rio printshop them and wet wet so on
a board lucy and district e print you can
stepway tube collar program photoshop
they will start  whether the desktop
revolution
with a human impact on the imaging
industry are all that was man meter
chains
are you that there are various changes over time
who became people te smartphone we
which is to stumble dear brie heft
spinning and believable i hear no distract
is  disruptive
say so we it's the species and
disruptor adwords tag and then he was
singing the bank rita sing everybody good
there for him in the camera and everybody
action and they camera in the poc  ket at all
times dat research fundamental changes
what is it earlier you no longer have to
pay for heavy photo you take and you
communicate charges camera in your
pocket
no matter where your work on the
gathering cleese in the rest kan world and
lightning on the nan  desu a wok
among everybody people camera in the
pocket and hence mortgage photos
so stay now to become cats and stuff
so that was it chains have the
smartphone in it and
the phone industry basically with changes
the teacher sing sing sing slijk-ewijk
that  already so kim outside of the sing in me
so emotion in the academic world
and now you will see a dead my
tea break sauce in the photo you have
octo classify yo on total images you
capture o'right images how we click
packed so to  stay he is be used for
well smart photo enhancement oil from you
then lost well wooden legs settings in
or out to chase in a photoshopped the
evil few very innovative applications
auto
based on a clicked  from barton
to forbid you for photos so then will
load of changes or love disruption the
internet if we seen the same it also
him the effect that you can share your
photos the entire world
and the old media communication and
networks and less facebook's instagram
soft world
twitter  all of them have allah of
phototools image in a day and that was
if your chains it was not in the imaging
industry but he so have at impact
when imaging industry will lots of
times haven't a doctor silent happening
your sympathy color and your myrthe  muscles
the cost by the so eat pizza
crust so vieri correct of the so more than
it is an ai in in management
use cases dollar and so so we caught the german
also very fundamental
crazy that the smartphone camera is
now become the most important and
reviewing  the vice yes and minnie
we slept billion in out my charcoal scooby
google and it will be the other way around
well the
pruning I click on your smartphone your
counter sand i  n you cut shopping
information or you can visualize it
becomes share
nike ja chair also want in your own living
room with just look at your life of
course so dead yet
see that who you are the beginning of all
other no static smartphones all that
coming
the viewing the  wise korea and the very
latest
die other fascinated by is there is who
are so what is it for 5 weeks ago the
mobile world congress in barcelona
solidarity free for very high and
smartphones the piri-piri for cameras
and experts waste flows t although he
also  at time of light pepsi center in the
back of the cameras have here at the
nooddle you pray with that iphone and
and tms were partly did the the village
censor and the front of the camera will you
know her family
fancy me pike an ef facts on  your
face
well je carol die scient cameras and they
can measure the des en en the placement of
any sort of artificial object in your
and fire my tattoo grow the sewer warm until
your viewing phone is
called  he sorry poor became tremendous
bank
onesies high-end smartphone sexy comming
to market
you that the history here black studies
also cool use
so the charge to do to binet
bones see the picture behind jurgis signs
have the goodyear in the helps to all the
week  will you cora collapsing yes because
it's now unable to innovate nose so
minuit so fast that there hardys arryn
the partners from the company sa bacon
rose but innovative save his fall and
mine all the wietse de with the market
position of the photos and needles
application  of artificial intelligence
at materials die undead sensing is
sofa smart because it's finnish time so
proposition 2 may be made more sense
terminal is there won
winds biology developed with and
capabilities
this is your bosom mars of evolutionary
strong and and the wine who are the field
necessarily kind animal looked bobo dioulasso to
make the house making you rustic
pictures in store now for free basically
video store for that freebase agree  that
is now just where i sent in her buttocks
that the capture and we simon that you and well
for her in dining room chair robaeys yes and
too much about the automation technological in
and reactions and the albus answers on the
in a real a sierra and they are  golden
shimmers god so we can be the depth and
sitting and horse loads martha ordered
europalia this is now something religion and
perception for this goal
billion loose at ziggo and that leaves
elemend or yes who collenteur you
could do it
your holistic imaging would fact that  you
if
the camera order system and the stein's wat
syndet in which you can image kind of a
rose then toemai die act upon in die
king to review my and 6 ok
gramm somebody who looks like grandma's
is crossing the street in my car
ipad de slow down  you can rest assured
I can be any gryphons can be made
sl small cabinet it is fate or
beast visual in your implementations
in robotic engineering it is central
you have all those sensors and you
have
computing'  my that's the other element
toe outings it i can browse and
getting better but yourself the cameras
marine die vice that's so build
computing' my soul power full of something the
cms
most computers were two three four years
ago is not better and the zodiac power
peace
intenso been able to computer can of
things and apply
algorithms and take lean to the fly they
and direction is happening in real-time
well the cupboard that those five are scandal and
know it guess to internet of things' you
can on that vice is  when you
see you gloomy that in front of your house or
the camera
you see your camera some sing of wise
and
sensua text like it simply dry mouth
come by or whatever
you guys so that's all you can do yes
in the application overboard
imogen video classifying for the
purposes of the things simple life goes
on google images and big booty script
to an images or exactly the
problem is it haunted and hq we build sleep
for the j yes start a spin center soon
he v  iews of your building mass and do
content the video and photo
research on industry analytics your
typical building red stuff yes yes what
syntrus is zoey have and jokon french and
a tail l'asticot the mobile photo
connect it him as for what you your
start-up  and we demons billabong branch
or something and what we do who is disc ripe
in the take or the bowl sometimes what is all
about zoey know how the mobile in their
and know how the picture in there and
connect if i do that silent and applicable to
both  old trams mobile and photo kino
who is one in the cfo at the move beyond
app so mobile something to oh quickly took and what
you do
mobile is part of any thing like in there
in soest
yo internet and the beeping could m itself
about yarn internet  company very
original should be it lise
buy internet jews was the problem by
business would have is an
internet version and latvian thing batmobile
closest do it mobo we took out or
to take or come from then the
second thing was
pictures
white  is already so interested pikachu
you then just him pictures or for or is lee
video and video is coronation porter epic
lee als be easy meteor sympathetic
lewitt
video editing and be able to handle
ifile but where we blow videos in
order in which you who is whole range  or what
week hrtf audio
the diet would those jews we'll be in
between pics and videos and billions
when we do instagram the more on
and better time yo take up the
ladder full of them there in the queen that
cheese
that seems to be something that  do you
prefer tracks kind and check my
season demographics sets
not so be super short they violet a bit
cooler than just a photo would
save you through folio's
little journey i also build on the turbo again
that knows if it is a photo those
greenhouses photos  limmen the mobile
was once of and old comfort scores
fysio of first
which those back into the philosophy dat
summers communication after we here well
in twitter or whatsapp in messaging
apps or in and i  nstagram the communication
start want violin and that we all those net
social networks and messaging apps 7b
camera battery there so you your star of
us and the text and would bye bye bye then
illustrate the photo and the photo add the
what they castle by a  de and that that
was war in the plague her people through
close or and communication and start again
the photo and video
de and your mindset and place through the
yes you also in itunes and dual script and
sexy videos to do really a message
platform in you  king de
significantly more they do van about that
projectile emotional camming babes
facial expressions yes
jef together you guys are here ken have
voice of whatever
music dat je
illustrates door point at er if yes in and
there were what is bombarded with with text
and information mapping samsung this
in the nature visual and i of violet
movement or its sound is
the ladder people gravity test task and or
communication and so you will a lot youfirst
yes-r where dat the moving in well dat de
french be  d through the connection so that there is 5
djuz' space choir name like public
in centennial is what anyone share
oh yes yes and a light in the transition
to visual first so is this scoring pike's
hear your ipad how even the driver that
simple is  fire video for knife
sometimes audio format aerostep physio
listening and no need a wow dojo grass
more platforms a containment potential
inspiring more people with the sametime
box there what that sounder long with the
visual emotional cues or webcamming
step 10 times it does that wi-  fi or turn the
switch first that your and the
is it possible that your house and garden in
two
into two three dimensional grams white in
the arm and trio the stairs de
like your next visual secondary who are
you
I think you who remembers  good are a
van or who
disruptor ferry drastic changes or
we he [ __ ] the school motion the five
such no matter what you look at around
you could have thunder you have
website it flow so long white wor  dt you
see you will find extra information
he might look at you and and download
or have one
with technology innovation
drivers generation is a quite right
and up peeps need a
workflow google glass is then fingers
something cool you
see lesson disruptive in  in the sensor in
otys tracking, for example, you
often do look at you have never met you
before in san marino corner mike can see
you know so lure a party identification
that the linkedin oh yes and mentor
yes and with you with such comfort  his
sale am back and it miriam just
looking at you
yes well this could be fransen this day oh yes
that lets go oh dear happen job we
like hammering
meat so so defective type kind of look
around you
and there it is extra layer of
information or
content good as that of boring be
creative yet not necessary iphone or
learn but can enjoy knives of rising
kenar is silent boontjes trouble a
space form factor
yes holding hoping smartphone that'  s
not ideas lose not amused left to 100
you can driver too sametime let go with it
solidified yes so the farmer sympathetic
listener quiet
yes want that backstep i was your
kind of flippo of your cell and pull lenses
care sector so indeed could be one of
this competition  co2 know so very
interesting thing but being able to
project the om car window screens en
en m the driver will see some
some information what is a plant of
her already so warnings for cars to close to
them and the deathly door mijn Actie
see some other  stuff seems to do a lot
became a shot
bet snood er here yes here dark
disstrack the driver of the city so so
using screens if i screen they will we
a loews 2 or or do haha what i silen
e so long or startups and strap
ess company  disappeared the figure out
what is the right the vice
suit the innovation of lungo's
it's not quite perfect and the kind there
only first attempt pc will puff this
good enough
my baby whale's head it it sometimes
d  discussions title route but couldn't do anything
about germany in the group with my and
peace freaking came out a judgment is
often lost due to compression minute
also a user duncan earlier this point
with the daily coachman he married
fast or a good enough go as long  we
look at it easy the dot and this
billion people oh yes yes yes yes so
your smartphone a poor sms devil teacher
youtuber well i have santing in the window
of your house and your look-out said when you your
nature is here turn and families  ad van
beurden so warmer
yes so three of fierce or something for
a few craig time that the picardie the
feature begging the most flexuous
youngest get information and not least
cranchi yes who is the most beautiful biutiful
is this film by jozef devillé view
design and technology our  winners cue
so there is a kind of script and my
merckx with minus
newest be a very very hard brings a
get on an ladder across the country and
and the take it also became just as
hard you can send an  email across the
country and now it's the de person die
hare die millions and millions of a
larger subscribers who have to live this
method used to millions of people around
the world in so often hear the of
my brand
dissemination forget to the teachers
body  on our bee in this gave birth first yes
yes
well ultimately something
comes out here and anyway is that percent
ryan could v it with given that just
a knife it is physio-fit applies to how
people passive information so official
for as at  the note is an
advertisers have just for ever write
something which fizzle are out of photos
and then rather beautiful so video you this
being noticed it like a store who one
becomes
am so text-based information
seem put earlier i already overloaded
with information like  battery member
and so if the loop it is i to review
get something white violin in it
you join more likely to share it on
twitter or other shape it so
that shows the nature of en d  e hour of
visuals
so became income race with summary
tax officer foto c less yes that
becomes a very powerful and and to some
extent
5 euro could be come a viral 10 that was
a dick to cut mute it
ideal link to to to be successful is a
communicator to large audience
june elements of all of those
that thing violin is to mad at cans
terrier a lesson nail polish we want
qtex tony
look here is the president of the
knights t-shirt reaching noticed is the
craziest oil bath nv body  if savior that
video and the rector yes is interesting
gays more they can be it can be
have bully along the other buoys hey
becomes a video component to wait and put
your right and acted penny of the
level of
comments is also en charges 4 have
lots of  cloud i in goals for the
station src installation people which is
can we has iphone feel like and you
those managers to do it now the
airport is resting
this is it this is interesting well
then moody's d  e nut is had to do white with
white was who for those huge two
drivers in a yubikey fingers to
order
the buddha used and analyzing with mike
what is what is to our process like you and
your teams
how you analyze what is specially the de
who they  new generations kisses huge new
farmer report technologies de ven
demoona enclave sloetjes de friend and
warner manual the scoring an amateur
technologies dave never had a red
technologies like the smartphone in with
lineups a city so you will keep such a
you in a wise de  the friends
die for visual arts iblies die de
generation yes this kind die pennies what
can or research who is who your department is
min sam sam richards willie focuses on
the article er
solution er solution right on the ikelen markets
and lightweight well we do i have
study round  the the kik
photography and barely there is what
he called him dick discourse of you
together this kind of mixing bin under his the
cupboard and like foto
taking photos for adding photos then not
w  ie you left for the live in
ebeling service' snapped tvc like you and
your company for lessons his eyes driver
hey noah own couple powersearch die
effects mixmax and money
they can
die engaged to door fotoshoot somewhere
watch cinema or copy whatever
sporty and fantasy  of like real
estate photos so that they study intention
well what the focus notes to the chicken
rotten in him or herself in this case
outings men have good you know and the
mood or what can or innovative how
important your solution would be old wood
so  the sbc blew a meter or pulled
with a ladder venders in dead space and
what of this service providers and
tribe maintain this frame
keep the thief and what can the problem
stick tackle or
not that's nice of collective story
click want your levies  cool
photographer version videographers in a
series of likes and from cisco that orange
ceiling dqt
potentially therapy moodle wedding
event jaap and that's why there are many
boo  k use the afternoon kymco keep
yes and of course sample authors yes so
just kees uit rok white service provider
the i damping coming my this that you the
scampi compricon sweet escape
interesting enough da beast in indonesia
that is sometimes tiers she would
depart from  sal over the word if a
little sit still is in the us and that's
exactly how it works light eye for
birthday guy i came to the cios
for the founders and when you
interview him the defiles it's you so
like many startups value for struggle
even  over on roblox with iroh here was
the want to tell something
hehe like inside photographer and
although it into it but if i go chair
the got the head rested your guy in he's
never in the pictures and even so we
men have an easy way for
dissidents  te he me i showed the pictures
with
from where the participate in star and and
also be in the pictures would file here it
is this company when we will keep them
going back to early presse your
resea  rch in this case
he interview love the service
providers horeb di vaio app developers
and and try to get good sense of what
they're doing and decision about to
market
resource the studies bbq purpose
surveys and gather pond eating
ideas have we have dan  that you
barred it from big vertonghen that could
be one and then again sorry pressions such a
test you well the end user research is
dance floor focus groups which is now
watch mill group of people you
interview with more in-depth so deep and
things members  white at the top picks and the
crèches again two big thumbs through fit
he is the plant the food
to end-users qualitative to the
end-users and if it's more the jews the
providers the developers of the public
interviewer people and get some sensor
van Koning aan en aan de and love and
love by the job interview variety
did you and am certain you have so be
calm very good because we're trying to
go en intact this a friend
I do the career of the fields of wh  at
she said you economy of photo and video
and do in the interviews
danny your support white friend
Nietzsche serbien many the craster
worlds news in the fields and in
this file op rind is my new
way lukkien jaar already on all this you did
at your  stick in it okay
fulfillment business this would go in
really proud is because can you
know tours as soon as species 3 different and the
staff a creature of rose gold banner
deal with a and after classes student i
allow'
industrial area social development for
sale yes usually  of the instant
be couple or teen sex on the mos o
of the der weck free will or or then all
that research and space kind of a crash
and like in this case a kick photography
mosul before you will and in a research
support and that's what  is even so
that they ow of monetizing knowledge
hello the photo kind of onko wering ear
and gamble knowledge about what's going on
in the sea cow's in to go free
newsletter tweets in die jentj  e know you will lead you
to something a new people and
not being who
buying called gate order and to it and
things suitcases with smother it something at
weekly newsletter warisoulx locative
and trends in industry and news
r and after the know that man it  ice
the knowledge is or that he den hef and
our red shirt have my top picks
at home console wifi do you want
an ehm just came out of diet
academic world and god and then in your in
with spots mission and vision
who the english who it  panel very early
on knew of the first image recognition
vendors and no one of them is ex die nou
wat is amazon recognition
rack en is white tea sodeco require bij
amazon
yes so again seller the ladder topics of
so en and have a discussion
space is available  is that we if we research this our
week and yes what about the lion bigger
little deeper in a few own the
conference
such begins on for the
newsletter freya i a trainees and the reporter your
provider and in the c  onvention driver
stepping in also one
is sexy in steffen solution center
studio in that period when he is dead
office building
could you elaborate yes yes for syrian
kurdish a new and zip october
and force passes through the ford ok oh yes
and no
well ok when we  well we buddhist
teams am new bring together 4 we boot
and least receive the is as symbols
menu prince jelle the reports a
monoprint jews the panels are drivers
of the similar teams like us at the gate
before 12 o'clock fell i will be there will so
yes some  some of them but anyway we
glory the cassette dick stada almost and
all show wants to have panel round out and
older and if we have specifically in
the frisian john what pino something to get
everybody's mind in leith in that
ecosystem or
well imaging vendors like franssens  your
it on I the caspar lee few of the
imaging van' so already in the photo twinspace
and lead
but for that is in fc sochaux or flyer
in the scanner price
or a door is  it on i wanted you to know how
can you man the ice photo engagement' with
you and things print button in a real
my wet thing to people's your mind
corpse hey jang going to judge the app
and what is the genius who in surf
suggestion we  that you judge who already
wanted choir product before or time photo
so that they top me who has the youtube
space was already double bed more fiction lesson
there has the was there prediction of all
business may be the first time you take
and dysphoria family in the  muscles for
ever nuclea maybe you want to order one
fesa come in the print
exec lea en en lettre qwise evil pray
you here no education also to en
industry that he was so then it in suit
a being and and sweet and be quiet
intention the simple  tool who comes for the
smartphone there a like collectors
photos to my free download an app for
you who come with doing something
and the pore just before that sven loop is in
people avalisa okay living photo book of
to the two pages
if you think  kind of come into the picture
is a vendor the people are doing price
comparison like oh and in that article there is
hard the photo industry so a ladder
discounting
and heard well and so sell your in a
you in a cup additive this thing
singing price the skoda
well  seems like does the compli they
have it our show this solution at alcon
fans dee
image the solution that a lot of indiana
female men have nice pictures too that
you forget him share on facebook in a photo book
member you do your smartphone and
click click click  and you belong photo book
layout
already the deadly charlotte with the color you
need me anyway in view
market 30 facebook people are not
because i put the unique solution no
their man to other ones old in the world
after that then the target price shopping sites
od
ok wow  coordonnées my hi i am
book but those who care outside via je
be surprised armenia is still care about
het nou willing to pay money for en dat
er hoorns other fields
je panel ideas with  draws or seriously yes
yes and and
something so good cursor some times a little too
direct for you will or research en selina
you have on my partner
yes we have had we ideal en pau
you based on that research what should be
done if you don't be  done or so in
sociology mooji
and then action or something interested powder
pen autocare so right now i'm a very
peaks with those worn out smartphones the
handle apps and so turn the mouth
campina impact have the bones pokey
pokémon go a kind of thick thick  year ow
battery has experience
maybe title the house implications
for shopping he never insisted
so german interest who knows nie he
sell read it off en loop and then
buyer or app that fall so like a you
feel i can use the steps  and to
snarl
the closet it so i in on the quite clear
ghosts we do or that fall plus like
how your what what state gonna be with
potentially you should is impactful lesson
that iphone and was wit the front facing
that center this good now it is  something
c  ould be very interesting anyway beautiful isn't it
that goal to may be who you need to
be in the museum there must be websites in the grocery store
yes it seems the ishiya have output my
phone it you here at the jury precisely
locate the setting or in your  team
such a tablet gay and realistic object
it i lost it that in the plein box
with indian that a front of the plant
bozhev i again destruction center for that
small or artifact so that the the minimal
wat icann a medium the ipad you through the
loft in ov the webdeveloper both
thinking knew frohnau and or so om the the
camera side the fat swans wit apps and
they
samson and wow ok and
past that had such a converse them
and outs om not dead crystal clear so that
an intresting panel to see  what de wat
de impact will be
je and having those people have
conversation' in die al die built en
tom ik
yes yes how the word is de this this
next year of how je foot ended up doing
this transaction from van
in many ways of photograp  hy video
archive videography
see this like it's going troys some kind of
euro and a subscription and dep reality or
kind of ct scan or the next
and it takes a lot of time so a warm
hope we the kings like a the young
people in the dead words  with a ledge
grazing
guy squeak dead boring a symbol your
career toys world peace out the
strypes affairs and night
drones inspectors consumption and holly
will do you for aap i think that in
many ways to see a ruling
of you and experience yes yes so you will
tells about being tv en pipa satori
everyone organic and all that
but that they continue for ktm and many
technology can be used in many different
ways and om modern technology
champion for the better or worse is you
know with
uw nou in italy and find out what  not
solely in the imaging group the you and
your items of really work program fancy
i have two and make
be vernier products the airfryer
coins it cancun use resources ww
smarter or that is already short
bed  while soup discussion thread
hardworking the big 5 tech companies where
and place
ar ex-lief right into the seo
you could never now us at department of
defense force be used in
this if a here also your net very hard
to tell the for them the  and that for us
again danny
here is also face recognition gray wicker
bags duvet and photos that cash piece him
at the stance a photo in just a
car with cleo playsuit settings face
recognition can also be used in cameras
the government or also all my  the
particle the china' and here a lot about
rug and you heard within week golden time
every step is in a gave my database
and that's something it is though is bing
like that time in a rollin' ovc love
for this is such a  before computer
cheap in the of two sizing yes the
best gift is biologist
boot kissing in your most people on
using the technologies and for charlie
is in us and technology is willie
inside find it
the johnny dusbaba in the bottle less
that that  would disease understand the
help that is still a work each of you
do not need a more about
yes how do you cell the chair and how you are not
willing to sell this to
relations at think wat silicon valley
more recently of reality en and
privacy en  security
all these debates is entered such valley in the
us recognize in thinking whether
i self-regulated or even the sewer
driven by green and make money so that
sara let the parties have ok the
government correction cares about
due issues looking for must regulate
mealtime
de f too cool involving of humanity
the primary becomes easier to the use of
the pressing charger power phishing is
something i frequently discus to the
show and why not sure why you're
perspectives on a crazy industry die
fix
ah yes yes zoë bye
lucy  ruiz store is best push and is
indistinguishable whether the president or a
grand jury ex lease and datavideo arena
tower family that oil synthesize yes yes
yes you do from
images the dat comp  leet he artificial
and then look like a regular
de was andré voor cats [ __ ]
university research project on that
but detection julian earlier what there
potential
toppix' and the conference it not clearly
based on a research project at snow de
top i him and
ever to be  left there alike most
people single jersey work with high
enough to herbarius
yes he long to minutes it will be a
combination of
incentivizing the trick is pro league two
in cents Feith
developers for technology companies to
tackle the problem because it's not of your
states problem
big  aim way of and for 7 dive teams
how it works people go
to this that fall technological
funding between market for five you
just choose the top me and the problem out
of to good news of the heart
so it's real there is sam setting that it
will  i make sense for them to identify
the pics
hi wouldn't be surprised edgar how is of
or willy tackling out he do well this
after this blockchain the section intere  sting
is a solution
for when one photo design and fireplace
even to play a b that is totally
verified that there was still means men read
in ask what the plans is nice that
photos and donor or third is that was the
radio buoy photo that already  is my photo to
begin with van had such
slots and could be part of the solution
with the cubio dab solutions all know
begin thing that you this hurts you such a pain
or stitching analysis and see this can now
this has to be you  an artificially
roller shutter
photo out after idle now or maybe you
had to be trusted effect rams of the
kind of the persons accounts oh yes
nobody could post some video of us
omnia pro seriously julia self a to we
videomix guests yes and that is  see it in
foil
here at energy what do we think
coming of fasting source den 18
blockchain the ladder has the potential toe
or fantic die hore origin or the
photo and mix order in the transaction as
in weert is comin' on their
je  and we our who w  ie you to start or
using blok chain in india sing so is
so his other plans showed
sap that you and in this samsung gear
idiocy kitty pop hot along the way as
you after the centralized is the larger
than people chicken hot along the way  for
making the contributions to the rats the
in manchester the video to
in the innovate cold butter and scare 2
and wetter and wetter the direction of
your boat is the future of images and video
with both
yes is another women in fermentation
field whose om
risk the drone videography or
first haircut in your eyes dinosaur
mother and son and they are best bryan oh
who has already done it before
yes I see what they then yes go it too or
is also our at that time there is that
and October
who  do then we will learn this your i
go to do you want what this was literally les
medite mdf de die standards sled
destructive fires in the why can't i was
not let's you way for
and ecologically you see it was there
dream for  thor refer to w  hen there any
shot photos of my daughters from zen
center rosa became completely the saxony
with a third was silent house star so
i'm fed up with is dream de dol
mon like landscape and then there was a
postal worker in his wildtrak who went
and then the  very few
mailboxes this was still standing and i
was finishing is red and more in the
video or form and the role about the
place in international media
or so much work prequel also ok to
levy to hide it built
power or dream discourse for
videography  in this case
and yes it chintz is another fascinating
there you hold bills
hang on they can be mini one out types
first time
yes yes i broke up it was oil of six
where i will be used for music and warm
white led i ask this  to combine or
so the fibers and the coming and and this
track postal office which how this
zantinge was totally useless but that's
what the have to do
and you thought you were a pleasure
in this and of the videos that some
motivatin  g go in there i could add the
good life a set with video to get 3
here from the the stock photo for for
alarm money but i just wanted old
i had it was sit personal story to
see ya
you all good yes this interesting win-  win
the creators know the myth decision of the
wine sao paulo janeiro brazil luxury
salts other than the the hulk real-time
instinct barrier system your videos
also creative commons on people can i see the
videos and push talks about lady called
ruben steeman door channels the call  is
is for the content idealism
spy spy and for educational purposes his
appl
student to another another fire
other his
field aerobed is the impulse or who
apparently the global purchase account
for review action photo kind of space of
those assessments a delight week a map
share my first and seating suite for
station wagon and care or all those fairfax or
waste facility services for ever and
beyond our viewing resource expressions
by sony who they do is him  view
be here signe in the mass the
white pollute the anchor
to be an awesome it's not a noise jan
aan borloo in
washes always too far for my home
do you ethyl it or leave it stylus boulders
en and partially beacause
your the who your the  market how we that
politics and sit and again
ultimately more focused on consumer photo
and video views
sorry from tronios i see the cups dream
use this commercial and agriculture and
yes and ewa sorry no way but i'm not full of
a homeless person
you feel so  do you become johan de the
two objects for billion people have a
dog gets in af yes yes
social this interesting house i now still 1
billion people get their devices die just
as full more than now
converse as shown on the global car show
boys in white rose  wit
b&b il capo billion people can i get out
with greer everton sat in a coalition
next aan en u last van hearts about the
know about the industry on construction
building in obesum those things you can
you can explain to without option1  get in
touch on a minus let par would be just
under on the other software sider tank
would be interesting the first set 15
santing
michael layers first enter enter the
scene and now we have no
the premiere in the final cut and we
kill him dead want clean  lightroom and
photoshop fur sketch is there really
a bot identikit these gorgeous
videos in images found so i know maybe
it also be done software science yes
wadden gesink of many things that the
white bio finds respect yes the service
or the so interview you anyway  back to the
belly the sec a job that he was in the
us than this live picture and yet
layers at the zinc what did this
first and a free service see that is to
my thinking about
facials in journal the effect it
this you  could change in his study to
the photo and they disrupted ssl goal
willems
so doubly wet on mindjet toe the pixels
en you can work for you very large
files'
and then in die and chicks okay well and through
the this resolution that r  esolution zo
die a day of doing things with photos or
videos that can still be like to many
de kan of output for much of forms
zo keep everything in tripoli op his so
keep your work in our team would you seem
at
had it could end  up being your home use
it is small resolution on a smartphone
of big screen
the cooker next r oh sorry you the i a
video is space corner
you will start shooting and
resolution the ones that really takes off
it can be if it is duty of  the sign
video in the long you are i in turkish or
you so demand soft five seater in white
so that edgar coercion concept of what have
always found for the important
it i die diode thing about this whole
industry is this so interesting to see
my ass research with  startup select to
rise in the
ukraine did you get your brother your
brilliant engineers and fun to eject
so you have it then people do now and
mmm
dh struggles and trucking and
thinking about technology and similar to
some  bodyguard of confession lord and
icon or or by their feet film
corporation zo you cia life because
all other barriers to and free to be come
die philip in the salon
yo source coach a
lot that the computing power is in in
the skye basically and do you want  know how to
water something similar to that such a dress
rss startup weekend ipower could walk in front of the cattle
while tied dee and the wright
implementation at the right time
it matters again very
young radio
yes small companies within masonry
successful in  and some of them
have both less problems
bikers
success story with a knife it earlier the
competition corbier city was a quite i'm
so hot wheels oh he the company and
lighter maar wat and management of the
ukraine i will be heard it may be  trendy
of two three types Juist time but they
were the once the first month at reef you
him
you take a selfie
and you can give him crazy world time effects
in the video like steam is coming out of
rulers then still n  aar that would this show
the best if he could also office in october
de we still in beta and in use got it
and offered it for a virtual
dollars and that you some snapchat
lenses
bars and and
snapchat this wheel will give you a breath of fresh air  stijn
die olie knows that
snapchat is monetizing of earlier om with was
studies our plen sixth code
now became tide singing the other
areas of the app would detection with the
marie back
simili cuir provided by fast
en you you you like working white white white
start-ups and developers who of praise
god honor and this was went that your skin
mount the prime time
yes and facebook has so cream vanden
borre buy that photo let me money that
this is something similar to that the valves
are field that does not hear inez en  caesar
effect region real time real time and
if so like a like that this is not something crazy
like i like you can get the
the next page duvet all the people want
to use what do you things in your
joris or tc op de pees
wat  what  mi mi mi mi mi jeske this is what
de en justice audi about a aan en gio
prochowski all you see any of his
will i know
the big deal that princess across countries
in games work simple deventer camps in
indonesia to politicians have to hurt you so
is that die mulder career or about of
technology and used to be a 10 the typhus
that the via na a check pen house within
sosyete white
traditional so cameras also know you
and that could fujifilm like oh it short
it
and this company
in the slides  alarm lesson high end
cameras pc
yes ok tip struggle to keeping well event
like the two don't think
chip and is is the powerhouse anymore is
it use to be china' action i sit on have
in this kind of deep and salad with some area
of imaging you looking it also means
what cameras the hall of things happening
in china'
with more the the types of cameras
they valence frieze i see the frieze i
steve and box in bleed in city frieze
i steve it is or the larger sniff with
the cameras  in a  reas of image
recognition
he is say it is well and russia
ukraine had of
composer kim van der sar beest there is
such a thing in ferries a little bit pure
application area but a jesse lee i had
in journal going back to digitize glass
and my isync
the high-  end turismo this do your camera
silently in quite well there be cause
the so cools you the rollers 10 subways more
than
price and even if quality least
this fair amount of learning and manual
action required him in people still do
that and it will be harder here
yes it is deep and less on the jews and
the fuji fun and they came out with
something that has been a tremendous
success first a jeep and tickler monty
no they what what i try instax
cameras would your like the also
ever cameras in many ways  that i could
also be this one and these wheels against
mistakes and more your
your print in real time here and en louis
gold the people who does it already kidston
teenagers
i was one of them them the fishbowl
print
then summer coat  en and like also your
routines do you have kids oro can you we
want we
people henk pictures among us with
deadlines xlii
of time mother is that where you not bio
who not
ride the work and for putting clichés
unwel this country develop more the
things first he  must need van den the
japanese camera company
good come on white sometimes in that is cool and
retro
and is a runaway success with 10th would
go to gold would and very get used
we success picas die instax printers
for van fuji db at themself cells
outside stone  song about unit is of
[Music]
middle ear interchangeable
cameras opinion the de miranda are dso
larsen and kill or kill this cell
and so all
point-and-shoot cameras combbind
what was it then and the success and [ __ ]
fact he saves show be  how i a
barry yes i am you an icing child oil
dvd find this so i tick this the word
bidet blanket of success each and in
pointed out you know
so you see the joke ever labeling
joralf in that simple ritual  el she de
tuna grace is a samurai ukraine
that so the front pockets of or visual
technology and jazz that other guests
world
ok great this is am super of a super
in my like myself or miami die 10
kilometers i will appreciate my
do you think so hard  i want your preview or
showing in thank you so much
how the cool air your mother tots in the
comics polo red us know your touch and the
campolo amstel live i know about what
your touch there in terms of your screen in
the message from the community  or to the
world get more people talking about
moritz light to the room photography
video ages of ding so who descried
gift left polo too hard work also show
is about explorer profit in
support argus and cinderella you
believe in ff you have to support simulation
bureau is well  a goal goal the figure
just manifest your dreams and to the
world and switching and you will see you
peace